eight
of the ten most deprived neighborhoods
in england
are right here in blackpool
and that's before the pandemic struck
the weather's it's bleak and uh that's
it's how people are feeling
it's bleak i don't think anybody ever
imagined it was going to get this
we've got desperate people turning up at
the sea kitchen every day
desperate people not just uh what we
would normally look after the homeless
people we've got families and
taxi drivers genuine people who have
just got no money
you just can't afford to live
how is that desperation manifesting
itself well the panic is struck in this
time around more than ever
the first lockdown was bad enough the
second one was incredibly hard but this
one
i just don't see it i don't see a way
out of it for a lot of people is
we've got people in business who just
cannot
make ends meet we've got homeless people
who are in hotels that are desperately
in need of food
we've got people ringing us up old age
pensioners ringing us up
they've got no food
[Music]
we're primarily set up to help homeless
people
but it's it's changed since the pandemic
started we've we've been helping oaps
people who are in lockdown
people who are caught up and not well at
home who can't get out of the house who
haven't got family members
they're just not coping when you come
along tonight you'll see a lot of
families people there waiting in the
queue for food
and and that's not a very nice thing to
have to do queue outside
a soup kitchen it's quite a difficult
thing for some people
[Music]
it's really hard at the moment going for
a pandemic and when you've got a family
of children and stuff that you can't
really support
these guys up here help you you know
what i mean they tell you to come at a
certain time they give you food
more and more people are just becoming
homeless and i think that's why these
guys
open shelters up for them and they put
them in b and b so they're not on the
streets where the viruses do not
mean it's been really bad honestly
it has people that have got money that
just ain't got it no more because
they're at work
[Music]
okay so this is amazing grace uh this is
where we serve the food
and all of the hot food resources over
here we've got pizza grazie
this is where we make our money the food
is sold out to the general public
instead of a secondhand shot we decided
on a pizzeria
and the main resource room basically
what we're doing here
is this is where all of the groceries
all of the hot meals that go out
this area here we're doing for these are
oaps
deliveries these are getting packed up
to go out exactly the same time the
drivers will all arrive
and it will all happen dead on five
o'clock
people it's awful when the first time
they come it's usually the wife the mum
and they're mortified they're just so
embarrassed that they're having to ask
for help that they've not been able
up until now they've been able to feed
their families and they can't anymore
and it's heartbreaking
there's no judgment there's no questions
asked if you need help and we've got it
we'll help you
and so the people do come back because
of that but it's really sad really
i mean i'm a mum myself my children have
grown up but that's really sad
when mums are coming because they're
desperate to feed the children
we're a seaside town we're a tourist
town where we didn't have a season
we didn't have the illuminations we
didn't have all those things and so a
lot of people who work in those kind of
jobs
in cafes um in the shops in all the
viewers on the pier they've all lost
their jobs well you know
and the furlough's been caught more and
more hasn't he i mean it was
great at the start when he was 80 but as
he's been cut back more and more
people are just feeling the pinch now
and it's really sad because it's
in a talent as well we're so dependent
on tourism so depend on the holiday
trade it's just
hit so many people really really hard
they're realizing now that christmas is
over and it's like there's there's not
all the help's gone now isn't it the
mental health level for
a lot of people has it's gone so bad and
it's it's the one area in in blackpool
that we struggle with
there's no real mental health support
and it's it's quite frightening really
to what's going to be at the end of all
[Music]
this
art is one of those things that can
really help people when they're anxious
[Music]
it makes a real difference to people's
lives
if they've got something to focus on
other than anxiety
i'm alice i have a mental health
condition called schizoaffective
disorder which i've experienced since
i was 20 it means sometimes i
hear voices that aren't there and see
things that aren't there
and i get very frightened and paranoid
um so that's been quite a big impact on
my life but
it's also taught me stuff as well
painting really helps because it helps
me focus on things that aren't
everything else in the world that's
going wrong you know
so i spend a lot of time painting almost
in a hopeful manner that there might be
a more positive future
after all of this
hi alice hi nick i love this shed by the
way
thank you so much i'm just wondering how
you're feeling as we go into this
this third lockdown giving it everything
that's happened over the last few months
um i'm feeling pretty anxious right now
i i really am a week before christmas i
was prescribed antidepressants which
because i was depressed and i was also
having some side effects from my
medication
but they sort of had the opposite effect
which made me very very depressed so i
felt quite suicidal just before
christmas
which isn't a good thing you know so i
sort of
what i do when that happens is i take as
many walks and i take as many
um i try and contact other people if i
can
if i'm in the place to i try and make
contact with other people
how important though is contact with
people for you
vital i have a really good support
network of friends so i'm
really lucky in that respect and i you
know everyone's got a family of some
kind hopefully
in whatever form that is i did get very
very depressed before christmas
it was horrible really horrible and it's
actually very frightening
but i feel like you know my friends and
my family too and
really um they get me through a lot of
the dark stuff
[Music]
oh you silly things come on girls
on i don't know where the others have
gone they might be down the bottom here
i don't think they like you walking
right close to them
i keep saying to the kids you are so
lucky to have a space outside no matter
what
even a small space but a space like this
where we can go the kids playing the
stream
and like we just we can go walking is
the garden like a coping mechanism
yeah definitely so is this a good decent
substitute
to keep you sane i i don't really
like cards
i first met joe and simon on the first
day of lockdown back in march
in much nicer brighter weather
it's a cozy cafe we make everything
fresh
i've just been and uh dropped some bread
crates off for rick
the guy who bakes for our cafe and he's
saying he's probably only going to keep
going for another week
the week building up to that lockdown i
think it was a bit of a shock wasn't it
[Music]
there was so much uncertainty and i'd
had to sit down with all the staff
and and say i i don't know what's going
to happen you might not have a job we'll
try our best and that was really hard
as that week went on i remember that
just being such a difficult week not
knowing what was happening with schools
and
trying to get to talk to the staff and
give them some assurance but not much
so then when they locked us down and
then they announced the furlough it was
a huge sense of relief in terms of
the staff but just an uncertainty about
the business
we are a cook chump place but
due to the low demand we're going to
have to swap to a
kind of cook freeze place he said
originally that there was going to be a
second wave in the winter and it was
traditionally it was always worse so it
wasn't under any impressions that would
be open by july
i thought well we'll be closed but um no
i didn't think it would as bad
i didn't think it would be this long
what's your full name just for the day
uh chris conway chris conway mbe
i'll never get used to saying that ever
are now currently on our way to the
other side of blackball to deliver
a meal and some food um to an elderly
lady and her daughter who are currently
shielding
back end of 2020 i received
um an email and it said uh
do mr conway blah blah um you are
you are being made a member of the
british empire
i said since my girlfriend i said what
does that mean
long story short i've been awarded an
mbe for
services to homeless people
people weren't expecting a second
lockdown so everyone thought they were
going back to work they were getting a
job
they were you know they wouldn't need
any support and everything's going to be
okay
and then all of a sudden it's been it's
been hit again
so it's it's almost as if it's even
worse the second time round
it's just got worse for the people that
are receiving the food it's a lifeline
good evening how are we i'm good thank
you i have this box for you is that all
right
my mother doesn't live in blackpool she
live originally lives in rumsbottom
but i've got to look after her so she
hasn't even seen her own home
since last year it really is hard
you don't feel like it's safe to
actually cross this threshold
and get out too much not too much but i
have to do it
how is mum doing
she's okay
this is tough yeah very tough
tough times i'll just be glad when it's
all over
are you worried about it i'm very
worried about
that yeah because if i go out
what if i catch anything and then bring
it back to mum
i'm a vulnerable um
it's scary it's really scary
this is the reality isn't it yeah it's
really mascara
well okay i'll see you next week no
worries see you later
bye
we rely on these guys did you before the
pandemic
no
it does get better but you do need that
human contact
you really do out of really hard stuff
comes
a bit of a revelation as to how to
survive things you know so i'm quite i
feel really lucky i'm here now
you know really lucky actually
i spent um four or five years pretty
isolated
when i was in my early twenties in a way
you'd had lots of
little lockdowns yeah i guess i'd had
lots of little lockdowns in my life
where i couldn't go out because i was
too frightened to go out
if anyone is going through a mental
health problem right now
when you really struggle sometimes you
come out the other side so it's always
worth it
[Music]
i am always always stupidly optimistic i
really am
and i haven't felt doom and gloom but as
it's gone on
and gone on and you think okay
how long is this going to go on and how
much is it going to really affect do you
see businesses closing
like ours and people saying i don't know
whether we're going to manage this or
we're going to cope or we're going to
survive this then you think
it is a hard time the stopping in the
starting and
we can't open no we can't open and
that's been really stressful
i'm actually really missing the
customers and my staff as well really
missing those guys as well
and it's great to see them and they're
really fired up and they want to get
back to work as well
i think it will be okay i really do i
think that it's
we're going to have a busy cafe again
and people are going to come back in
their droves because people
miss it desperately they miss going for
coffees and they miss meeting their
friends and they miss having lunches and
so i think that we're going to be okay
you